what's going on GQ this is post Malone
and this is on the rocks as you guys can
see my collection has grown like quite a
bit since the last time we've done this
I look like a hobo so they need like a
reason to talk to me so I just put my
lights on and I'll be like hey could you
help me out or something you know it
feels good to grow up and wear cufflinks
and watches and fun stuff like that so I
kinda you know spend too much money on
watches I guess yeah I feel like watches
are a great investment you know
especially you know the factory diamonds
and you know the super rare collectors
pieces that's you know stuff that stuff
I'm always looking for and always you
know down to buy and you know keep or
you know save and flip or give my kid
we'll start with this nice rainbow
Daytona I think it's pretty butch and I
think it's really unique and really cool
and it's one of my favorites it's classy
but it it still jumps right out and
grabs at and says hey look at me I love
this army green aqua now this is one of
my favorites too and a good friend of
mine mark helped me land that with
protec and it's really really special to
me so I'm lucky and blessed to be able
to
we'll stay in patek world this is my
Nautilus Factory the getti band and
bezel combo with pave to fill it in this
is one of my favorites whenever I feel
like shinin whenever I feel like
stepping out and making some trouble
this is this is one I'll rock and I'll
wear it with a nice with these nice nice
rings here this is a nice stone that my
friend Isaac made for me on my opposite
ring finger here so I kind of got this
to marry myself because no one will ever
love me like I love myself this one's by
Richie Rich and it's just a really cool
but get invisible set ring and I like it
as a pinky ring because it's really in
fat and awesome I'm not a big green guy
I don't think I usually just do a watch
just a watch to match the outfit and
then whenever I feel like really
stepping out out where you know a nice
ring or two
[Music]
this one's cool that I have on this is
our m12
and this is one of my favorites and it's
so light and it's so it weighs like I
don't remember the stats exactly they
told me it was the lightest turvy on in
existence which makes me feel like a
spaceman which is pretty pretty cool I
think this is a Bubba Watson here this
one I really like I wore this at the GQ
party the other day and I think it looks
nice with like a super dressed up suit a
little sporty look with the watch and I
think the light stands out
I like the subtlety of it because it's
like if you look at it and you're not a
watch guy you'll be like okay I don't
know what that is it's got a rubber band
and everything but this is one of my
favorite watches too
[Music]
this one is Richard Mills skull Asia
edition this is my most expensive watch
million dollars I feel weird saying that
it's cool because now I have to talk
about in my songs so that's why I did
that's part of it too
I think the skull is so cool it's badass
and this is just a nice tasteful piece
of jewelry but it still has that edge to
it I love this one
that's my favorite Angel City jewelers
here in LA he's the best and he's the
sweetest guy in the world and he takes
really good care of me and that's really
important for me to build the
relationship and he's just an incredible
guy and he's always been there for me so
this was a gift for my birthday from the
21 savage after we went on tour together
and he gave me this watch and it's a
really sentimental piece and I'm gonna
keep it forever this is one of my
favorites also because of this story
he's such a sweet guy and so grateful to
have friends that give me goodies and I
really I know he doesn't you know rock a
whole lot of jewelry anymore but we had
to get each other watches so I got him a
nice icy Rolex for his birthday in
Atlanta so there's a lot of fun it feels
good to give back skeleton Hublot I love
Hugh blows we've got a little beat up in
it but I love this watch and I love the
tactical nests of Hugh blows they're
great for everyday you know use I live
in Salt Lake City so I like to rock my
tactical gear and these are great great
watches for them my manager Dre got a
factory Royal Oak and I got this
beautiful Ferrari Hublot and it's cool
because the sides are all sapphire and
such I just think it's really nice and
refined and I think it's a very very
pretty large this is my favorite watch
pie by far it's big its bossy and it's a
real real bitchin piece whenever I step
out with the potekhin and the rings I
gotta
you know title home these are all from
Angel City jewelers I love just rocking
the chain by themselves I have this
there's this nice all big cat type deal
which is cool as hell
TMZ said it was 250,000 I just let them
tell me how much it is he made this for
me as well these are my two favorite
chains so this is my cowboy star and my
little Dimitri head which is you know
the post feed little guy and then God's
team America's football team best in the
world I love rocking these with the you
know the ice and just looking it up big
white gold guy I love rose gold I don't
have a lot of yellow gold
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my hot boys chain that the defense of
the Dallas Cowboys gave to me and
inaugurated me in which I'm super
honored and very blessed to be part of
and this is yellow gold.rose is hot as
hell
sack and quarterbacks and just getting
it done so we love that this is ashram
life medallion pendant that sway gave to
me after tour so this is super special
to me this is a new one as well I love
my friends now I gotta get him a chain
[Music]
and then these are my electric field
chains that my managers got for me I
love these these are great low pieces
you can just mix and match it's the
studio that I work at and it's you know
a conglomerate of mines are that are
just genius this is a Chanel candy
necklace it's not real candy but I think
this is a one of my favorite chains too
I think it's super cute it's very unique
Jesse from the neighborhood had it I saw
him in a picture with it and I stole his
swag
Richard milk cufflinks this is cool this
is cool to me I saw a bunch of pictures
of him online and I always wanted them
but I could never find them but I found
these and I'm like it's really good
oh this is I think this is Roberto coin
I got these in Vegas there was another
one I lost it the baguettes are cool so
I'd like to keep my nice little theme
going on so it gets him to watch and
hear and on the chain and the Rings as
well
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
for your first piece of jewellery make
sure you really think about it make sure
you really know what you want a lot of
this stuff is a lot of money and it's
something that you're gonna want around
for a long time
take care of it keep it nice and clean
so that was it guys thank you for
checking out my collection
you know I'll see you guys around in the
next couple of years and I gotta go do a
photo shoot so thank you guys very very
much oh yeah
[Music]